uh my mom died when i was seven my my
dad went to work when i was 17 never
came back he
he passed on a shipping disaster in
england
an only child being orphaned at 17 that
was obviously quite pivotal in ways that
i didn't fully understand
but it nonetheless what i've recognized
in hindsight what it did give me was the
glimpse of the isolation there's that
feeling of separation which is what most
people experience they feel disconnected
from life which is why life is all about
survival
and if i my experience with myself is
separate then i have to
fill in the blank right be pretty be
smart be wealthy
so my experience of separation was very
visceral
because it was literal in terms of like
i am by myself
but then in hindsight i was like wow i
think much of it was so that i could get
to the
place of really having such a profound
compassion
for every human being's ego which by
design is the experience of separation
so i had the visceral experience the
literal experience so that i really
could
fully relate when people feel like
they're not loved they're not good
enough
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose
is to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability
and what you realize is that we are so
much
more alike than we are different to
quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and the show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
[Music]
i love to hear what's possible but then
of course hear what you do so now
i would love to hear some of these
transitional moments for you
sure what got me to this mad ability to
break down even the
the thickest concrete facade i just i'm
so fascinated because i like you're like
my guru for
uh unpacking you know starting at the
beginning my mum died when i was seven
my my dad went to work when i was 17
never came back he
he passed on a shipping disaster in
england where the boat capsized
hundreds of people died it was pretty
pretty horrific because it was all
covered on the news by virtue of the
event it wasn't like he was by himself
on a motorcycle or something like it was
a nationwide event
um so you know and i an only child being
orphaned at 17 that was obviously quite
pivotal in ways that i didn't fully
understand
but it nonetheless what i've recognized
in hindsight what it did give me was the
glimpse of the isolation
right so you gave the image of you up in
this tower and your concrete dome
and there's that feeling of separation
which is what most people experience
they feel disconnected from life which
is why life is all about survival
because primarily we want to belong and
if i
my experience with myself is separate
then i have to fill in the blank right
be pretty be smart be wealthy you know
wear the right clothes blah blah blah
whatever it is
so my experience of separation was very
visceral
because it was literal in terms of like
i am by myself
it wasn't like i'm in a relationship
like a lot of people are they could even
be married but they feel
lonely or they feel isolated or they
could have a family but they feel
somehow
you know discarded by the family so they
feel separated that way but they have a
family
i didn't have any of it so at the time
it was just very painful and i didn't
really know how to process certainly my
mum when i was seven
but then in hindsight i was like wow i
think much of it was so that i could get
to the
place of really having such a profound
compassion
for every human being's ego which by
design is the experience of separation
so i had the visceral experience the
literal experience so that i really
could
fully relate when people feel like
they're not loved they're not good
enough they're not
you know valued whatever it is because
those are i would
assert aspects of the isolated ego
so that was that was you know a bit of
background
but my quote you know awakening was um
just over 20 years ago i was sitting in
a rent control apartment in santa monica
everything that i possessed in this 200
square foot space
and i'd gone through a breakup with a
girl who at the time in my understanding
of love was somebody that i loved
and i'm not denying the fact that i
loved her but my version of love was
very limited like most people don't
really understand what love is like and
i think they might have got a glimpse by
virtue of your courageous sharing
um but she left me and i sort of fell
apart
and couldn't sleep and lost weight and i
was calling all my you know guy friends
like how do i get it back and
for the first couple of weeks we've been
together for about a year and a half or
so maybe a little longer
and it was really the first time that
i'd felt that essence of love like you
know i'd had girlfriends and it was fun
and
but this is where i felt like wow this
really could be something
long term meaning like a marriage or
whatever in family
and so when she left i really sort of
fell apart
and we spoke for the first two or three
weeks and then there was this hiatus
where i just hadn't heard from her for
about five weeks and
um my mind was ruminating i couldn't
sleep at night and i i could even
remember literally one night i woke up
my mind was so active with all these
questions trying to figure
everything out that i literally screamed
shut up to myself
like how loud so that was a first anyway
cut to
the five weeks of sort of having no you
know completing communicado
and i had these just like annoying
questions like
will i see her again is she dating
somewhere else where is she
will i have love like that ever again
like all of these questions
that were just like literally quite
unanswerable until
the moment where i got the answer to all
of them and it was so cathartic and it
was so profound
profound that the answer was three words
i don't know and at that moment like
well i see her again where is she
is she with someone else will i have
love like that whatever the question was
the accurate answer at that moment given
time like literally
was i don't know like that was was the
answer
and when i when i got that i realized
wow that's the nature of life
like i really got the fabric of the
universe in terms of the linear
progression of time through human being
is complete uncertainty we don't know
what's going to happen
yet the ego by virtue of the fact that
it's living within a container of fear
is always trying to figure it out like
because it wants to survive
so you've got this complete
contradiction now of life is uncertain
but the ego wants certainty
and they're in lie suffering so right at
that moment i realized not only the
answer to all my questions
that gave me access to the actual fabric
of life which is uncertainty
but for the first time in my life i was
totally okay with it
not that it mattered if i wasn't because
the answer was still the same i don't
know
but for me personally i was okay not
knowing
i i've never felt such a degree of peace
and freedom
in my life you know the ripe old age of
whatever i was in 29 30.
like it was just like it was insane and
i can remember
and this is where the story gets even
more profound within 15 minutes like
literally maybe 12 30 minutes of me
having this epiphany
the phone rings and it's her
and she's now crying which is what i was
desperately waiting for and she says i
miss you so much
so now this speaks to the quantum
entanglement and genetics of
everything where as einstein said spooky
stuff happens at a distance
is his like definition of entanglement
so she now it gets even crazier because
not only was she like
like calling within 15 minutes of me
releasing my version of a concrete dome
of like
you know because my fear was of loss
right no one's gonna begrudge the fact
that as a guy
falls in love mum died dad died okay
whenever you meet someone of value hold
on as like hard as you can
so my form of love was very genuine it
was very loving very generous i did all
sorts of things for her but it
still had the underlying fabric of what
i was here to reconcile which is my fear
of loss
and so life had to fulfill on that for
me too just as your mom bev
couldn't call you because if she did you
wouldn't have to look at something
right so likewise for me she had to
leave otherwise i wasn't gonna get
my soul was here to do which was to
reconcile the fear of loss
so as soon as that dropped and there was
this like literal cascade of freedom and
availability
because i was now open she could
actually meet me and that's where she
felt in ways that she couldn't be
conscious of
but she called me and said i miss you so
much so now i was
like you i would assert it's a bold
statement but you're a different human
being by virtue of what you've just seen
and i was at that moment a completely
different human being
i i descended a resonance there's a
different form of frequency
so she did come back for a minute and it
was beautiful and we still are in touch
actually we
you know many many years later which is
beautiful but
um i i that relationship quote had
served its purpose for both of us she
got a lot out of it and i obviously got
what i got out of it
um and then i went for dinner after she
called and she was out to finish the
point
so she was actually in australia like no
new zealand she
like she was on the antipode like she
couldn't be further away like you both
were having your coffee something you
normally do together she's in a whole
different time zone whole different
continent
literally as far away on planet earth as
you could be and still the entanglement
theory helped
so that to me was so profound so anyway
she eventually flew back a few weeks
later whatever we had another
beautiful couple of months and then life
took its course and we went
each other's ways and and there was
definitely a few years that we weren't
in touch and then through
of all places instagram we reconnected
and it's been beautiful
but um yeah so that that was really my
one of my big aha moments and that
was certainly i would say the catalyst
for the journey of what i do now is
recognizing sort of like
neo at the end of the matrix i saw i
just saw the matrix i saw all the green
numbers and i was like wow i spent my
whole life and
not even holding any kind of criticism
myself but being so scared of losing
anything of value
so when you say neo and the matrix and
the green and the black and the numbers
and
i know this might sound like a dumb
question yeah but do you see things
different like literally see things
i i'm saying more than see i feel okay
and i do i mean like no one would have
picked up on that breath that i picked
up on i'm not saying no one that's a
bold saying but i'd say 99.9 of the
world's population wouldn't have picked
up on the fact that energetically
i saw a shift in the way that your
breathing
was automated because of the release
that was happening in your physiology
by virtue of the fact that you were
seeing so i see all of that
energetically it's not like i see a
number
but i can feel i see the water behind
the eyes you weren't crying but i could
see it was accumulating
so and then i can also the feeling
matches up with sort of the
cues that you start seeing yes so i can
feel the essence of where someone's
going i can hear in their words the
choice of language
where there's constraint where there's
protection
all of that yeah does this make it
i mean does this make life easier or
harder for you
like from a personal standpoint work
fantastic
right like you could unpack me here in a
podcast that i'm supposed to
you know like probably was no good plan
to cry today
right um which is beautiful and such a
gift
such such an ability um
but how does this show up for you
personally
um that's a good question i mean
i think with what's going on in the
world right now particularly it
sometimes is difficult
you know because i see the pretense i
see the lies i see the corruption i see
the particularly on the male side the
abuse
you know and abuse is a strong word and
i declare it as
abuse as anything but the absence of
love you know so
like meaning people think of abuse as
physical and sexual and of course that's
disgusting and
abhorrent but i would also say that a
child that is not
held and loved and adored and that's
abuse you know if that's not
present right so you look at what's
going on in the world under the pretense
of like this is for the environment no
you're adulterating
mother earth mother nature with gmos
covering it with glyphosate
which is like ruining our soils ruining
our rivers
yet you're saying that you're here to
help planet earth
no it's a complete front so that's where
someone like myself where everything is
so categorically clear
that can be a little difficult and even
though we would like to think that
people with resources and billions of
dollars and they're educated
would know better than to be doing what
they're doing and the mandates and the
tyranny and the lockdowns and the
you know like you what's going on with
even the
the v word the vax and like you know the
mandating and you've gotta
like you don't inject health and
certainly not to somebody who's healthy
and certainly with something that's got
a 99.7
survival rate you know these are very
sensitive subjects
but i'm just speaking categorically from
a place of like understanding freedom
understanding love understanding
vitality to the depth that i do and i'd
assert
there's not many people who know those
depths as i do
then all of this is completely asinine
it's completely insane what's going on
right now
even just recently john hopkins noted
that 73 74
of the people who died from covert were
obese if we had a system in place
government politics health care which is
not health care it's sick care it's got
nothing to do with health doctors are
experts in pathology and pharmacology
drug dealers yeah they are literally it
is a drug
you know and a disease management system
but if we really cared for human
vitality and health
then the things we would be mandating is
that we would be mandating
don't use glyphosate don't eat gmos you
know
make sure gyms stay open make sure
people understand meditation the
importance of sleep
make sure people understand the beauty
of community and having conversations
like this where we get rid of our
dysfunction and our differences
that would be where we'd spend and we
wouldn't even need the billions that
they're spending just spend a few
million to educate people
you know that that would be then an
indicator of a unity an industry that
cares about people
pharma is not celebrating each quarter
when their drug cells drop
that would be people don't need it right
that would be an indication of a company
that is dedicated to health no
that would inspire a lot of people to
probably be fired and
more ad money to be spent to try and
promote the sale of drugs
they just want to make money it's a
business we're all you know in our own
way trying to make a
livelihood but when it's under the guise
of health care that's when it becomes
disgusting
because it's not it's about sick care
and disease management and selling drugs
and now especially with this sort of
mandated energy that a lot of people are
brightly so
feeling defined about and resisting
because it's
going back to the feeling it might be
what someone's saying but they're
feeling like no this
there's something up here even those who
don't subscribe to conspiracy theories
whatever conspiracy theory means that's
another narrative
that put out there like anti-vaxxer it's
just such a dumb statement
like what are people going to accuse me
of being like an anti-cocainer
or like i'm an anti-cancer yeah i'm an
anti-coca-cola because i don't drink it
like
right no i'm pro-health right i'm
pro-vitality i'm pro-love i'm pro
like people like really maximizing their
own potential
so all of these statements that are
thrown out there are sadly
driven by you know these agendas and
that's just where people are at so
where am i at and is it difficult
it is but again i just keep doing what i
keep doing and i keep resonating
with whoever's ready to listen and i
keep bringing as much love as i can even
for those people who think that they're
doing the right thing and that
whatever agenda they have they need to
have more control they want to have more
money i'm like
you got billions of dollars like
seriously you need more like like
just let people live their lives and
let's you know as cliche as it is from
whatever the la riots many
many years ago what was the expression
like can't we all just get along
can't we all just get along we'll just
get along so apparently we can't yet but
i'm doing whatever i
can to uprise you know people's
awareness and consciousness so that
people go oh hang on a minute
you know it looked like you were coming
from a place of caring but actually it's
self-preserving in its nature and you're
disregarding the most important part of
your life which is yourself
and when people start to really
recognize and revere life is the word i
use like on a life you know
like yeah when i was a kid maybe i'd see
a spider and i'd kill it you know
because you don't know and i'm like
that's
a spider like i mean do i have to kill
it could i maybe put it on a piece of
paper towel and take it outside is it
that difficult
you know so it's just having a different
conversation about how we look at life
we value life
each other right now unfortunately we
live in a paradigm where there's harm of
self
you know we just saw it on camera harm
of other and harm of planet earth that
is the paradigm we live in there's
harmon abuse is normalized you know i
sort of mean today which was
it's so telling that you know he said oh
thank god my
my my son doesn't have to put up with
pepe le pew
you know whatever that's yeah like pepe
le pew they just cancelled him
like again like this whole canceled
disney thing whatever oh that's right i
just heard that there's can't there's
all kinds of disney shows
yeah so dumb like so they canceled pepe
le pew and he said thank god that they
cancelled that
but at least my son can play auto theft
or whatever they thought of that
i don't know video games neither where
he can kill someone and burn a hooker to
death because he doesn't want to pay her
like that's okay although the other one
was like you know song of the year
is cardi b or whatever her name is like
that song of the year but dr seuss is
like completely inappropriate
so that's what i deal with from a
perspective of what i would say is
you know some pretty decent eyes yeah
it's madness
it's absolute insanity but i hold a
space and i hold for the new world the
new paradigm that people want to step
into which is more harmonious
which is a more loving which is more
based in vitality like even here we just
nudged in the right direction because
you found more love for you you found
more love and compassion for bev yeah
and that's a healing so that's what i'm
committed to i love that
and do the best well you said yourself
others and the planet right
yeah but it so it's starting if you love
yourself a little more
you're gonna love the other person a
little more yeah you're you know the
planet
like they all it's a it's a they all go
hand-in-hand it's a natural cascade
as they say hurt people hurt people and
that's what we're seeing right now
there's a lot of hurt people who are
really hurting a lot of people you know
and it's
what the thing that i struggle with as
you know being a very sensitive
man which i like about me is the harm to
millions of people
under the guise of this is for your
health and safety
you know and if farmers said hey listen
we don't really give a [ __ ] about your
health but we're making
a killing on opioids because it's not
only something we give
in hospitals but people actually become
addicted which is great for business
like
i kind of have a little bit more respect
you know because it's like at least
they're being honest you know
so we've got a long way to go we've got
all of the industries
agriculture politics like education
you know they're all built on egos which
are founded in hurt and being scared and
so people are going to do whatever they
have to dominate and control and
but i still believe in life and that
people really fundamentally want to come
from a place of love and joy and
you know we all want that same essence
of we want to feel
happy we want to feel well you know well
is this the great awakening then
i'd like to think so i'm committed to it
i'm going to keep doing what i i can to
i'm with you keep ushering you know like
we got another one i gotta cry again
guys i
i'll let her i'll i'll go there whatever
whatever takes the healing whatever's
gonna help the healing
my healing is your healing right yes as
i said you
you know as as grandiose as the word i
use but it is a nudge in the right
direction by virtue of the fact that you
just came out of your concrete dome you
came down to
the earth you've connected with me
you've connected with your viewers
and you know now you get to connect with
bev you have a different
resonance to come from which is not a
victim of her behavior
but rather your own perpetrator and that
you can be responsible for in a way that
makes you a bigger human who can
contribute and let other people see
where maybe
they're being responsible for things
that they don't want to quite own
oh cheers to that wow yeah i want to
play this interview back for myself
about
15 times welcome everyone to do the same
yes if you want what a beautiful time
like you know not bad for our first
encounter
right yeah so weekly sessions
for the next six years i'll just invoice
you that's fine
the good news is like i can handle
listen at 38 like you know
like i mean first of all thank god
because that's like you know perhaps we
just took out
god knows what are the potential issues
and relationships and physiological
sicknesses that could have happened the
cancers of the world which i could speak
to a lot about the energetic
transference there but
you know like do a whole a whole other
show on just pure wellness
yeah and that's what i got coming up
actually in middle of april
like a health workshop which is healthy
not exactly yeah i don't know how far
i'm going to go down that rabbit hole
it's just a 90-minute thing but it'll be
fun
but but anyway my point is you begin to
be it catches people though people want
to be healthy
they want to lose weight or they want to
look better they want
anti-aging and so you know whatever
means to get people
engaged is um you know i mean i keep
hearing so much
i'm being in la like you know kids they
want you know
their wine to be you know uh biodynamic
and you know vegan sulfate free organic
and you know like
kids like kids that are like would never
go to a fast food
restaurant because they're like no i'm
not gonna eat that stuff so there
there is some waking up going on there
is it is it is happening but
um yeah i mean it's funny i drive around
town and i
you know from my perspective as a
visionary i look at like what's
what's the potential of a human being
right and if we look at it
you know as a species we're really
really
like embarrassing you know like i mean
there's a great meme it's like a it's an
alien meme or extraterrestrial meme
where
it's something like oh um you know
something about making contact or
or are they evolved or how involved are
they and they go they have their guns
pointed at themselves
yeah this isn't good and if you put
gun put anything in place of that right
we're
self-inflicted self-calm self-abuse so
yeah
i mean if you just like people watch
like a lot of like us do
like at an airport or wherever we would
previously when we were going out
but you know you look around it's not
like wow
like we are inspiring as a species i
mean
this is no judgment it's the state of
affairs it's you know it is what it is
but like john hopkins 75 percent of
people who died from like
um covet were obese you know i think
it's four
in five are overweight you know these
numbers are pretty horrific
so if you were to look at the sliding
scale of a human being's potential which
i love i'm all about health optimization
like if we look at pharma again farmers
doing whatever it does
but they're they're managing disease
that's sort of zero to minus 10.
i'm a zero to plus 10 kind of guy like
health optimization biohacking i have a
hyperbaric chamber in my house you know
nice see that's a commitment to health
right versus trying to manage a sickness
right
but anyway people doing the best they
can no judgment because sometimes people
hear this and they don't know what to do
because they're on their meds and
they're doing the best they can
but my point was driving around town you
look at some of these
businesses and i'm not going to call out
individual names because again that's a
business
but these fast food joints right you're
driving up to a hatch where someone is
giving you
food and i get sometimes it's just an
economical conversation because it's a
it's affordable but at what expense in
the long term
right and the expression i use is like
you know and we've heard it all many
times but if you don't want to be
responsible for your health now then you
are saying you're going to let someone
else be responsible for your sickness in
the future
and so um i was just thinking you know
what point
in the evolution of of our species will
these fast food places just be redundant
like they don't belong based on the
evolution that we've gone through such
that our height of frequency and
consciousness is
no one would ever eat at a place like
that so they don't they don't
exist well it's our participation that
keeps it going yeah and the same address
said
so unfortunately sometimes it's because
it's cheap or something like that
yeah but like at some point in time we
have to start caring more about
ourselves
yes and and and even if something's
harder putting value of
putting shifting the values of things
right you know
your health and well-being other than
you know fitting in one more meeting or
who knows whatever it is but yeah um but
it is but did i
for sure no matter what the institution
is
structure business it is our
participation that keeps it going
yeah if we don't like the news stop
watching it yeah because i promise
when the ratings go down and no one's
watching it anymore there won't be any
money to keep it going no i i you know
again not that i'm a poster child for
anything i do what i can and i come from
a place of love and help as much as i
can but
you know if pharma was reliant on me
they would have gone to our business 20
years ago
right exactly because that was the last
time i touched anything right
and that's not to say that i would need
something in the future and i'm
grateful for acute intervention and
triage and emergency
amazing trauma exactly i mean it's like
magical how they say people's lives pull
them out of a wreck
you know tiger it's like woods just was
in his crash a friend of mine had a
brain tumor they
robotically went in there i mean it's
amazing for doctors for sure
and i think people like sometimes poo
poo the whole thing
and i think there is absolutely the
conversation of like let's bring the
best of everything like i'm an ayurveda
practitioner
ayurveda is brilliant for diet lifestyle
and preventative and real health
yeah but i would be remiss if like
someone was in a car
accident and i brought them to my house
and i said hey let's rub some turmeric
paste on that
femur that's coming out of you you know
that's nice let's try and put you to
sleep with some lavender here
sniff this here does that work are you
asleep yet don't worry about the fact
that you're not breathing it's okay
use it as a meditation no my lungs are
punctured
all right okay we don't we laugh we
digress
but everything has its place and i think
right now there is such a
there's a skew because of the
manipulation and the control
and the greed and you know really these
seven deadly sins or whatever we talk
about like
just a little bit too in play as far as
i'm concerned but
let's keep having the conversation to up
level everybody's awareness and the
awakening
and the consciousness more love you know
thank god you pulled you out of your
concrete dome
and now you're not like walking around
frolicking somewhere around here
yeah there i am liberated and everywhere
and loving everyone and yes so
that's that's a good step in the right i
feel good about my day today i just
made the world a better place damn it
you did
i just have to say yes yes show up yeah
be honest to be vulnerable pleasure to
be with you my dad thank you i'm excited
to see what unfolds for you now
huh well you're going to figure it out
because we got weekly calls buddy
okay okay obviously we just scratched
the surface yeah
that was that was a good that was a big
one that was definitely big that was
profound because
because as beautiful and sensitive as i
can see you to be you obviously did
create a pretty strong facade which has
lent itself to a lot of success i'm sure
without that you wouldn't have been able
to accomplish what you've done so
even our quote-unquote protection
mechanisms aren't without their value
it's just to what degree does it
actually isolate us from even greater
potential
so i'm excited to see what you know life
brings you
and um what you get to experience of
yourself from this much more
liberated loving and available aspect of
who you are
thank you for opening it up yeah that's
what she said
good ending thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button